I'm often asked by parents what advice
can I give them to help get kids
interested in science and I have only
one bit of advice get out of their way
kids are born curious period I don't
care about your economic background I
don't care what town you're born in what
city what country if you're a child you
are curious about your environment
you're overturning rocks you're plucking
leaves off of trees and petals off of
flowers and looking inside and you're
doing things that create disorder in the
lives of the adults around you and so
then what do adults do they say don't
pluck the petals off the flowers I just
spent money on that don't play with the
egg it might break don't everything is a
don't we spend the first year teaching
them to walk and talk and the rest of
their lives tell them to shut up and sit
down so you get out of their way
you know you do and you put things in
their mitts that help them explore help
them explore once you get a pair of
binoculars just leave it there one day
watch and pick it up and watch them look
around they'll do all kinds of things
with it for me at age 11 I had a pair of
binoculars and I looked up to the moon
and the moon wasn't just bigger it was
better there were mountains and valleys
and craters and shadows and it came
alive not the full moon because there's
no shadows cast when the moon is full
gotta wait for it to be a Halfmoon or
crescent moon and look at the edge
between light and dark with a simple
pair of binoculars I was transformed by
picking up a pair of binoculars and
looking up and that's hard to do for a
city kid because when you look up you
just see buildings and and really your
first thought is to look in people's
windows so to look out of the space and
out of living space and look up to the
sky binoculars go far literally and
figuratively that's what got me started
on the universe I might get some kids
you know started the same way
you